Hi everyone.
So, we'll just get right into it.
So, over the past few years, we as
developers have developed a series of
bad habits when it comes to developing
as a result of slow AI code generation.
And so, we we're all familiar with it.
We do things like write massive prompts
and try to one-shot. We'll make huge
commits, or we'll have our 10 agents all
on the screen at the same time
combobulating,
cogitating, thinking.
And so, about a month ago, we at
Cerebras and OpenAI released a new
model, state-of-the-art model, called
Codex Spark.
Codex Spark can generate code at 1,200
tokens per second.
And to put that into perspective, if you
look at the Sonnet family or the Opus
family, those can generate code at about
40 to 60 tokens per second.
So, in this new era, as we're starting
to see much faster coding models, this
is 20 times faster,
not only does it unlock new capabilities
and use cases, but it also requires us
to rethink how we as developers interact
with the coding model.
And uh a lot of these bad habits that we
had before that were generating maybe 50
tokens per second of bad code, unless we
fix them, they're going to start
generating 1,200 tokens per second of
bad code. And so, that is the topic of
today's
uh talk.
So, to get started, my name is Sara
Cheng. I'm the head of developer
experience at Cerebras, where we are
building the world's largest and fastest
AI processor.
A large part of my job is that I get to
introduce fast inference and fast coding
models to developers for the very first
time. And for most people, it's a very
exciting moment. There's no thinking and
waiting and starting up that you might
be really annoyed about. But at the same
time, as I said, unless we change our
habits,
we are not going to have good code in
the future.
And so this talk really is a practical
playbook for how we as developers can
think about how we interact with the
models in this new regime,
especially in a future where the models
are generating code faster than we the
human can keep up.
So I want to look back at history a
little bit. We've had a very exciting
past 2 years. The models have gotten
bigger, they're getting smarter, we have
bigger context windows. But the thing
that has remained relatively constant
over the past 2 years is coding speeds,
is model speed. So if we look at a lot
of the popular families, we have Gemini,
Claude, GPT, Sonnet.
Over the past 2 years, they've always
been within, you know, 50 to 150 tokens
per second.
And this is Codex Spark.
Again, Codex Spark is just the first of
many models that we as developers can
expect to be much faster than what we're
previously used to. And we even had to
change the Y axis because it's so much
faster.
And so before we get into the actual
playbook and tips, I want to talk about
why this is happening. Why are we
suddenly seeing such faster models?
And it's actually a very exciting
development. It's It's what many of you
probably work on on a day-to-day, but
it's There's so many companies that are
working on this problem all at the same
time. And as a result, the entire AI
inference stack is getting optimized all
at once.
And so breaking it down, let's go
through it really quickly. We have
hardware. This is a physical device that
inference, training, all of our
computers happening on.
One of the biggest things that we have
to think about with hardware is the
memory wall.
And this is exactly why hardware and
memory movement takes up 50 to 80% of
that latency time for inference. This is
where a lot of the frustration comes
from.
And so, when we are running inference,
we have to constantly move our weights
and KV cache values between memory and
our actual chip.
On the Nvidia GPU, this is the most
traditional type of hardware. All of
this memory is stored off-chip on
off-chip HBM. And we're now have a
memory bandwidth bottleneck.
What a lot of newer companies are doing,
are thinking about companies like
Cerebras or Groq, they're thinking about
how do we move this memory to be as
close to the chip as possible. And so,
here's an example of the Cerebras wafer
where all of the chip is
um all the memory is distributed across
the chip in SRAM. So, every core has
direct access to the values it needs.
Even more exciting, we have
disaggregated inference. And this is an
um disaggregated inference really has
become commercialized in the last few
months. This is why Nvidia bought Groq
for $20 a few months ago. And this is
also why Cerebras and AWS are now
partnering to serve the wafer and AWS
premium together.
So, in traditional inference, there's
two steps. There's prefill and there's
decode.
Traditionally, both of these steps have
always been run on the same piece of
hardware. Prefill is where we're taking
every token that the user inputs and
processing it, embedding it, and adding
it to our KV cache. This is a sequent
This is a step that can happen in
parallel, and so it's compute bound.
Decode, on the other hand, is where
we're actually generating the output
token by token. And this is sequential
and is, as we mentioned, memory bound.
Again, it goes to the same problems that
we mentioned before.
And so, what we're doing and seeing now,
commercially, is that we're splitting up
these two steps so that prefill is done
on one type of hardware that is compute
optimized, and decode is done on another
piece of hardware that is memory
optimized.
Going up the stack, there's the diagram.
Going up the stack, we look at model
architecture. There's so many ways that
we are training our models and shaping
our models to cater to our hardware. We
have specific layer dimensions and
memory and model size that we're always
thinking about. A great example is a
very standard model architecture mixture
of experts. Here, instead of activating
the entire model all at once for every
single token, we're only activating a
subset of experts for every time.
And what this does is it allows us to
have the intelligence of a much small
larger model for the compute cost of a
much smaller model. And again, we're
always thinking about memory and the
size of our models.
And a lot of people have been building
on top of this in recent years. An
example is REAP, router weighted expert
activation pruning. I had to read that
one.
Um and here we're looking at the
specific use case. We're seeing which
experts aren't being activated all at at
all, and we're pruning them all
together. We're getting rid of them.
Again, we're always thinking about model
size.
And then at the very top layer of this
stack, we have inference optimizations.
And this is where many of you might be
working in.
And a lot of companies that you're
probably familiar are also working at.
These are companies like Together, Base
10, Modal who's also here, Fireworks.
And one of the biggest things that we're
thinking about at this level is KB cache
reuse.
And so by storing and reusing previously
computed token representations, we don't
have to recalculate attention over the
sequence at every step.
And now I want to get to the very top
and most exciting part, the developer.
This is the current state uh what the
internet looks like or what Twitter
LinkedIn looks like. We have someone
running six cloud code terminals at
once.
A 500-plus agent coding swarm. Um
someone running eight agents across five
screens.
And I get how tempting doing something
like this can be.
I feel like if you're on Twitter at all
these days, unless you are doing
something like that, the internet is
basically convincing you that you are
living in the Stone Age. And that you
need to catch up.
But the reality, what is the reality of
what is happening in all these setups?
Is that we're generating massive amounts
of code that nobody is verifying?
And in the new future with much faster
inference, this becomes increasingly
dangerous.
And so, especially with fast inference,
we're now going to be generating
technical debt at a level that we've
never seen before and we're not going to
know what to do with it.
And so, I'm going to pivot now to spend
the rest of the talk on the practical
playbook and tips and workflows and how
we can reimagine how we as a developer
should operate in this new regime of
faster inference.
And as I mentioned, Codex Spark operates
at 1,200 tokens per second.
But it really is just the first model in
what we should as developers expect and
prepare for to be a new regime of faster
models across the board.
And so, starting with the first one, the
first category is just choosing the
right models and how do we orchestrate
our agents so that we're leveraging
different model strengths?
And historically, we always think about
intelligence.
There's no There's no secret that we as
developers are not particularly loyal
and that we will switch to whatever
model, whatever family is
the most intelligent at a given time.
And maybe we also think about cost.
Unless our company pays for whatever we
want.
And so, here now the inference speed is
a 20x difference. Now we also have
another vertical to think about, speed.
And so, a good mental model is to use a
larger model like GPT 5.4 or 5.3 for
your planning or your long horizon
workflows and then using a
faster model like Codex Spark as your
actual executor.
And so, here's an example. You might ask
your 5. GPT 5.4 to generate your plan.
You would generate a
You would spawn
all of your sub agents with Codex Spark
and have it actually
have it actually execute on all of the
steps one by one.
Another really helpful trick is to
actually make skills out of successful
sessions and capture trajectories that
are working really well.
A thing that you can do here is use a
model like GPT 5.4 to actually have it
do the initial harder larger task,
capture that as a skill, and therefore
making it a verifiable repeatable
workflow, and then having a small
faster agent like Codex Spark just do it
again and again in the background.
The next category I think is even more
exciting because this is a category of
things that just were not possible and
were not practical. These are things we
wouldn't do because we're tired of the
cogitating, gesticulating,
terminating
that you might have seen.
And so here I really want us to think
about this and internalize this.
But at 1,200 tokens per second, a model
like Codex Spark makes validation
basically free.
There is no excuse and no reason why you
should not be doing things like this.
Test suites, linting, pre-commit hooks,
diff reviews, browser-based QA
automations. There's all these things
that you can add to every step of your
workflow because it is instant. It's not
slowing you down and it's not you do
this all of this at the very end or
right before you're about to push your
code.
Another tip that I really like is
exploring cherry picking.
So let's say that I wanted code a navbar
and I want it to be midnight blue, I
want four different icons. I give it to
the model and and the result's fine.
Instead, what I can do with Codex Spark
or much faster model is I can have it
tell it to generate 15 versions in the
same time that it would have taken the a
previous model generate one version, and
I can cherry pick the version that I
like the best. Even better, I can
generate five sub agents that are each
generating 15 versions, and now I have
75 versions, and I pick the one that's
best. And this is great for things where
we really value quantity or variety. So
things like research direction,
different types of architecture
directions, or even just graphic design.
And the reason why I really like this
one is because it almost allows us to
artificially induce taste into our model
output. So, traditionally, with no
secret, it's very easy to sniff out any
UI or text that a model writes.
The models themselves do not have taste.
And the ways that we've kind of brute
force worked around this is that we
either create an example ourselves, we
find examples for the model, which is
time-consuming,
or we give the prompt so much detail
that we might as well have completed the
task ourselves. This is a great way of
saving our time
and also getting much better results.
The next tip is kind of more more so a a
mental model. Well, now that the models
are so fast, it should not be you spawn
a session, you go get a hamburger, you
scroll Twitter,
and then you come back. Now, you can
actually sit down, and it's a real-time
collaboration that you're able to have
with this model. You should view it much
more as a pair programmer, and this is
the only way that you are going to avoid
having bad code. So, you can sit down
and ask questions like have having it
collect all the context across your
repo, and actually asking it how does it
work, being the one in the front seat
making decisions and implementations.
The AI should always be helping you make
decisions, not the other way around.
The next one, I hate this slide cuz it's
everyone's trigger word and overused
word, but how do we avoid slop?
So, as I was mentioning before, it
really shouldn't be, you know, you spawn
10 agents, you never verify the code,
you don't know what's happening under
the scene. Someone asks you to explain,
you have to read the code for the first
time.
Now, you can actually have two to three
sessions and actually sit down next to
your code, and I know this is something
we're not really used to,
but sit down with it and actually steer
it. Understand what's happening, because
again, we now are now experiencing
real-time collaboration as we code with
this agent. You can be super specific.
You can think do things like ban the
model from deleting files, give it a max
diff size. The model have the model only
read and write, and even give it
steering directions. Things like only
change this. Don't touch types yet.
Wait, that implementation wasn't quite
right. Let's redo that.
The graph on the left is a is a helpful
mental model as an example of how the
developer, the AI agent, and the code
base can all work together and what that
should look like.
This next step refactoring is very
similar to what I was talking about with
the valid with verification.
Just like with verification, something
like constantly refactoring and cleaning
up your code automatically is basically
free at 1,200 tokens per second.
So, you can do things instead of doing
it at the very end right before you're
about to commit your code, you can just
re you can just bake this into your
automatic workflow so that after every
single task on that checklist is
complete, you're just asking the model
to automatically, you know, delete
unused imports, clean up unnecessary
lines of code, make it so that all of my
functions are structured the same way.
The last category that I want to talk
about, and I'm sure that so many of you
guys have already heard these two words
accountless amount of time over the past
few days and across so many talks, is
context management. But the reason I'm
going to talk to you about it again
is because let's say that historically
it took you 10 minutes
to fill up your context before you saw,
you know, the god-feared word
compaction.
Now, if you take 10 minutes divided by
20, you are now getting compaction in 30
seconds. And so, context managing,
especially with fast inference, is more
important to think about than ever, and
you can't get away with sloppy practices
anymore.
And so, all of these these really are
just good practices no matter what
coding model you are using or what
speeds, but a general a very high-level
framework is just always always break up
large tasks into smaller bounded goals.
And this graph on the right is a good
mental model for how how full your
context is will then affect your
behavior.
The model behavior. So, you always want
to avoid the 80 to 100% because you're
going to get compaction right now. We
all know uh some things might get lost.
And so, a good way that you can think
about how do I externalize this memory
so that I can have these small bounded
goals. Like, what does that look like?
So, an example of how you can do this
and set up an external memory system
that is persistent every time you set up
a new session
is with this four-file system. We have
agents.md, which is where we're actually
defining all our agents, our subagents.
We have plan.md, which is what we're
creating at the very beginning, and this
is where we're just generating the
entire plan and step-by-step
step-by-step checklist that we're going
to go through.
We have progress.md, which is where
we're keeping track of what's do we need
to do and what has been done before. So,
every time you spawn a new agent or
session, has no context. It comes in, it
looks at progress.md. It sees what's
been done before and it's like, "Okay,
here's where I pick up. Here's where the
next task needs to be done." And then
the last is verify.md, and this is what
we're using at every single step to just
make sure everything looks good. It's
clean code, and we can move on to the
next step.
And so, an example of this is again,
leveraging different models. Using a GPT
5.3
or 5.4 Codex, having it create your
plan, and then having your GPT 5.3 Codex
spark actually execute the checklist one
by one much faster than before.
And as a final slide, I want to do these
um a few helpful commands for how you
can get the best out of Codex. Things
like permissions, experimental skills,
review, and rename. But, the biggest
thing that I really want to emphasize
here is that honestly, it's not really
about just having faster coding models.
What I really means is that the
developer experience is actually going
to become so much better. And when it's
becoming so much better, there's so much
more we can do.
And there's so many ways that we can now
avoid creating bad
bad code in a way that isn't miserable
or us staring at a screen for 30
minutes.
So, thank you guys so much for welcoming
today me today. My name is Sarah Cheng.
I'm visiting from SF. It's an honor to
be here in London. Um, if you have any
questions or need any credits, my handle
is milksandmatcha across every platform.
Thank you guys.